I love video games, don't we?
Marzia: Yeah!
Awkward Laugh.webm
I mean--
??
????
Pewds: What game do we have for us today?
Marzia: Ehh?
Overcooked?
[Jeopardy music]
[Dramatic zoom in]
Steve Harvey: "Survey says!"
Ding.mp3
Applause.mp3
Happy Marzia.gif
Pewds: I will be.. This guy.
Because he has glasses. ((:
That one?
Marzia: Yeah.
THAT ONE.
Pewds: We have to work together.
This game is all about...
Teamwork.
What happened was...
uh,
Trump became president.
[kletsnotgothere]
What the fuck?
Is that us?
THAT'S US!
Why are we so fat--?
[giant meatball has been spawned]
Is that a giant meatball? (osht)
[dramatic silence]
Is that a gian- ITS A GIANT MEATBALL!
spughetti meatball! ;D
I knew Sweden would take over!
[Sweden intensifies]
You need to pick up an ingredient.
[Marzia_destruction_noises.mp3]
Alright, gimme the, gimme the lettuce!
GIVE ME THE LETTUCE ASAP WOMAN
Just put it here!
Alright, it's my job to cut the lettuce...
...Okay.
[lettuce cutting intensifies]
CHACHACHACHACHACHA
Marzia: What is this?
Pewds: No, so put that down >:c
Somewhere else.
and then press "A" in front of that.
Marzia_realization.mp3
it is wednesday ma d00dz.
Gimme the tomato,
I will chop the tomato for you Marzia, don't worry.
We made a salad.
Marzia: Of course!
The most simple dish
to a meatball.
Ok so now the order shows up there and we dont have so much time
Marzia: o.
Pewds: Gimme the lettuce.
Calm down, Marzia!
Marzia: ur taking too long m8
Pewds: Oh my go-
Marzia: taking too long...
Pewds: COME ON!!
We gotta feed the meatba-
...i'm already stressed out *^*
Marzia: I'M TRYING!
Pewds: WHAT'RE YOU DOING?!
Arguing_Marzia_noises.mp3
Pewds: UNEXCEPTABLE
GORDAN RAMSEY: This salad is RAW!!
Marzia: Wait, why didn't you cut this?!! Cut it, man!
Pewds: I'm try-trying to cut...things.
Marzia: Stop cutting l e t t u c e !
Pewds: I am trying to impress Kevin over here.
Ok?
Marzia: o nO!
oH NO!!
Pewds: MARZIA, THE SALAD!!
Marzia: I didn't se-iek! (lmao what)
Pewds, reading: The beast will not be sat...
Whats the matter with- >.>
Marzia: I...I was qnq
right in front of him. ; M;
Pewds: I'm driving this-
...Are you driving it?
I can drive it too!
We're driving it together!
No no no, this way. ;0
Marzia: wOoOooO
Which way? ;o
Pewds: This way- ouo
Marzia: This way? <o<
Pewds: THIS WAY- >;0
Marzia: ...this way? <n<
This...pfff
Stop!
Ok, we're making soup now.
Enthusiastic_Sighing_Marzia.mp3
p r e s s u r e-
Pewds: The pressure.
Italian Pewds: Ah, we make a da soup together, Marzia
u wnt da onion??
I will chop the onions.
You.. You don't worry. ((: (be happy)
How do you put it in? (that's what she said)
Okay, I put one in.
Marzia: What do I--
Pewds: "X"
[amateur onion cutting]
Italian Pewds: You do not cut onion fast enough...
...wHaT aRe yOu dOinG?!!
yOu cRaZy wOmAn!1!!
Ok, put the soup there.
Marzia: Here?
Italian Pewds: There.
here.
You were gonna put the soup in the trash, you crazy?
THE SOUP IS READY 2 SERVE.
MARZIA!
GIVE ME THE SOUP!!
oH MY GAD, WE HAVE A FIRE, MARZI...
Marzia: Why is it not going into the...
BRUH!
Italian Pewds: Sorry...sorry, MAMMA MIA!
Marzia: Ohmygodohmygod, it's burning!
Pewds: Italian..
Italian Pewds again: Oh, you burned da SOUP!
Pewds: Gordan Ramsay will not be pleased.
Angry Gordan Ramsay.mp3
Pewds: Yeah, we make a lot of onion soups.
Marzia: But why do we...?
Pewds: It's our most popular dish.
Marzia: CLEAN THE DISHES, MAN!
Pewds: I'm tryin! >;0
Marzia: You are doing nothing right now.. <.<
Pewds: WE HAVE 10 SECONDS FOR THE NEXT SOUP!
HURRY UP!
Marzia: The soup is ready, just clean these!
if you are reading this this is your core message
Pewds: OHMYGOD CLEAN CLEANCLEANCLEAN
PEWDS: OKAY OK OK OK
OKAY, COME HERE COME HERE COME HERE
nO!
DAMN IT!!
DAMN IT // Sassy Marzia: That's what you get. <^<
Sad music.mp3
Upset_Gordon.mp3
Much sad music.mp3
Such Angry Gordan Ramsay.mp3
Disappointment.mp3
SaVaGeGorDon.mp3
Even More Sad.mp3
saLtYRamSey.mp3
Time's Up!.mp3
No Chill Gordan Ramsay.mp3
Saddened Pewds.mp3
Marzia: we got three-
*Offering of NONE CRINGY high five.*
*Offer accepted.* [Yay]
Mario music.mp3
Marzia: Wait, there are actual people-
ey eY EY
Pewds: You're burning the soup!
sHiT!
s H iT!
[Laughing]
Pewds: We are so bad at this-
Come on!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAA!
STOP BURNING IT and put in on the frickin plate!
DON'T DO THE CHOPPING, I'M THE CHOPPER!1!!1
Marzia Ramsay.mp3
Marzia: Bro, you gotta serve them!
Pewds: Yeah, but that's your job.
Marzia: Wha... Why..
Pewds: It's close to you-
[WARNING: ANGRY MARZIA INCOMING!]
Marzia: YOU ONLY CHOP!
Pewds: I will do the dishes, youyouyou-you can...
Marzia: THEY'RE BURNING!
Pewds: WHY ARE YOU TAKING THEM THERE?
oh, ok nevermind
aHhHhhHhHH!
DON'T WORRY, I GOT THIS.
["speed, I am speed" - Lightening McQueen]
Pewds: This happens all the time.
Marzia: How do you walk? e,e
[gottah goh fest]
shiit
[firefighter pewdiepie]
[marzia cackling]
Gr8.
Well, we'll never cook now.
*Gangster music.* [Triggered yet?] [Doe's dank meme's doe.]
You're gonna have to run
there you go, rUN!
R U N!
RUN AND SERVE THAT TOMATO SOUP!
GO MARZIA!
GO MARZIA!!
YESS!
What am I doing.. Why am I here? (same fml)
Would you guys like to try something? Marzia: Bro!
OH. Sorry, sorry! I'm trying to bring in more customers!
Teemwerk.
Times up!
We did good- that was good!
Marzia: Let's see...
[I will not settle for anything less than PERFECTION, DO IT AGAIN!]
[Laughing]
Pewds: Yeah-
Marzia: Disappointment!
They look so good.
Pewds: There ya go. First dish. Go.
[SCREAMING]
What is happening??!
[Swedish Chuckling]
What the hell ? !
Marzia:  F     A     S     T
Pewds: Ok. Alright. You ready? You ready??
Well it's not finished! There you go!
GO! ¡ G  O !
Yes!
I hate this job. I h-what do you need?
Marzia: a tomato. c:
Pewds: C'mon, we need three stars.
Marzia: What do you need?
E     V     E     R     Y     T     H     I     N     G *Demonic voice.*
Pewds: Give me onion.
Marzia: No, oh, its the mushrooms.
Marzia: Nevermind... [www.Done.co.uk]
PEWWWWDIEPIE!!: I quit.
Marzia: Hey!
Pewds: C'mon three, stars.
[discussion]
Defeat.mp3
Gr: GET OUT. [Gordon Ramsey Is Dissapointed.]
Pewds: We're makin' burgers now, Marzia!
Marzia: BURGERS ? Pewds: This ain't no joke.
Marzia: Bro, put it here!
Pewds: Ya gotta chop the steaks, and now-well you gotta chop it first
NONONO THAT'S NOT READY
ʛoʀɗoɳ.mp3
Marzia: I'm putting the steak there, OK?
Arguing.mp3
Marzia: We need communication!
IT NEEDS 2 BE CHOPPED
[Marzia Intensifies]
Burp.mp3
Ok, so steak takes a lot of time to make, right?
Marzia: NO
Pewds: so it makes sense that we keep cooking it.
Marzia: You're wrong.
Pewds: Listen, I worked in the fast food business, I understand-
Marzia: 🇧 🇷 🇺 🇭
Pewds: how this works.
Marzia: I don't want to talk.
Pewds: Yeah, got it.
Marzia: I said I don't want to talk!
Pewds: Yeah, but this one needs...
Marzia: I told you I don't want to talk!
Pewds: AAA
Sorry, I didn't know I was dating Gordon Ramsey, Jesus Christ.
RamMan.mp3
[focus]
osht waddup u wnt sum fuq
M O V E
Marzia: We'll be needing that one, serve it.
Pewds: Okay. Okay.
[war flashbacks]
Meme.mp3
!
Celebration Noises.mp3